the German tennis star Boris Becker has
been freed from a British prison and is
now expected to be deported from the
country in April this year Becca was
jailed for two years and six months for
hiding hundreds of thousands of pounds
of assets after he was declared bankrupt
the 55 year old was originally required
to serve at least 15 months but has
reportedly now received an early release
for more on the story I'm joined Now by
Ed mccambridge from DW Sports hi Ed so
Boris Becker he's released been released
early do we know why and what else can
you tell us about this case well it
makes a nice change talking about a
different Boris on the show for once
um that's why he served eight months
over two and a half year sentence uh now
just to be clear this is standard
practice in the UK for this type of
crime um when a foreign National commits
something like this they're sent home at
the earliest possible opportunity which
is why he's been sent home now he's not
got any special treatment because he's a
star or anything like that he's just
been deported because his time is up and
it's overcrowding in UK prisons now this
obviously relates to his 27 2017 jailing
for tax evasion
um that was all to do with the scandal
in 2013 in which Boris Becker had
borrowed over 6 million euros and then
declared himself unable to pay the money
back now he said at the time that was
due to a very expensive divorce that
he'd been through 50 million dollars in
earnings throughout his career by the
way so um some very all right yeah some
very poor uh Financial mismanagement for
him uh after that
um said he couldn't pay and then it
turned out that he'd hidden 2.5 million
euros worth of assets hundreds of
thousands paid to uh his ex-wife and his
wife the money was hidden and he was
caught so he went to prison for two and
a half years and he's now out after
eight months
um his mother 87 year old lady here in
Germany said it's the best Christmas
present she could have asked for and she
can't wait to hold her beloved Son in
her arms so some good news for the
Beckers this Christmas she's looking
forward to seeing him I mean it really
is the story of a Fallen Hero isn't it I
mean I vividly remember him um you know
watching him winning Wimbledon when he
was 17 years old and he went on to be a
coach he was a well-known tennis
commentator I mean after all of this do
you think there's still a place for
Boris Becker in the world of tennis well
as you mentioned he was an absolute
Superstar 17 year 17 years old as you
said captured hearts and Minds all
around the world uh six-time Grand Slam
winner he won another two Wimbledon as
well so really popular in in the UK as
well obviously that being the big
British tennis tournament was living
there since I think 2012. exactly yes
ever since he retired in in 1999 he was
working for the BBC working as a
commentator he spent two years serving
as Novak djokovic's coach as well
clearly a very talented commentator very
popular in the UK
um good coach as well
um who knows if you can come back from
this at the time of his sentencing uh
the judge in England actually said that
his career and his personal life are
both in ruin and I think we're about to
find out if there's any way back for him
in England you'd suspect suspect not
um but possibly he can get a job here in
Germany I don't know we shall see Edmund
Cambridge thanks so much thank you